there is one Republican running for the
nomination right now who's willing to
call out the obvious grift of
magicalists and others that has been
perpetrated by Donald Trump by Jared
Kushner by all the people around Donald
Trump and that one person is obviously
Vivek no I'm gonna
it's Chris Christie okay Chris Christie
is the one guy that is willing to say a
number of different things that are
obvious uncontroversial truths to
anybody even remotely connected to
reality but it's only Chris Christie
who's willing to say it here is Chris
Christie on CNN last night saying what
the hell was Jared Kushner doing in the
Middle East what on Earth is going on
with these grifts and all of these
people monetizing their proximity to
power Trump himself not a single other
Republican candidate is talking about
these things listen to this let's
remember something he's a billionaire
he's a billionaire self-professed
billionaire why can't he use his own
money to pay his personal legal fees
because he's cheap and not use money
coming from the public it's disgraceful
and it's a continued grift and look the
Trump family has been involved in
grifting for quite some time he was
doing this in terms of the people who
got paid out of this pack before whether
it was Kimberly Guilfoyle or other the
the Trump charity I mean there's no
there's no end to the Grift members of
the family Jared Kushner six months
after he leaves the White House gets two
billion dollars from the Saudi The
Sovereign wealth fund yep when I haven't
here haven't heard Ronda sanctimonious
talking about that Trump had put him in
a position to be in the Middle East what
was Jared Kushner doing in the Middle
East better late than never folks we had
Rex Tillerson and Mike Pompeo as
secretaries of State we didn't need
Jared Kushner he was put there to make
those relationships and then he cashed
in on those relationships when he left
the office so what Donald Trump's doing
now is just a continuation of what he's
permit his family to do and to be clear
what Chris Christie's talking about is
that Trump is now fundraising for a
legal defense fund for all of these
different cases for all these different
indictments that he's facing and Chris
Christie is saying why why does he need
to fundraise for that he's so rich over
the entire course of his time as
president why do you think he's not
using his own money to pay for his legal
fees because he's the cheapest person
I've ever met in my life
that's why and and what he's very good
at Caitlyn is spending other people's
money right and if you look at his
history in New Jersey do you think he's
misleading vote his voters his
supporters by uh I think those
supporters you know write a check to
Trump for president they think they're
paying for campaign expenses not for
personal legal expenses now in Trump's
defense I don't even know that it's a
trump defense there are cultists so deep
in the cult that they are glad to pay
for Trump's legal defense because they
believe that the indictments are
political that it's actually Joe Biden
doing it and all these different things
so like there I I think Chris Christie
is right that there are some Trump
donors who think the money is being used
for the campaign there are some who know
it's being used for the legal defense
and are fine with that and there are
those who are in this position where
they believe that the legal defense is
kind of part of the campaign because the
indictments are part of the campaign
against Trump which is a crazy there's
no evidence of that whatsoever Chris
Christie was a defender of trump for a
long time and for that he you know I
think he always deserves to be
criticized at least he is saying this
stuff now and no other Republican
running in that primary is willing to do
it
um here is Chris Christie also most of
them won't talk about January 6th than
these terms either but even Mike Pence
won't talk about January 6th in these
terms and they wanted to kill Pence but
Chris Christie will talk about it good
for him exactly a strong statement
people were killed Caitlin as you know
that day on Capitol Hill defending the
capital
um we had members of Congress who were
running for their lives we have people
trying to hunt down the vice president
of the United States Channing hang Mike
Pence right and Donald Trump the entire
time sat outside the Oval Office that
little dining room of his eating a well
done cheeseburger and watching TV and
doing nothing to stop what was going on
until it got to the point where even he
could no longer stand it and he finally
had four something in the afternoon put
out a video asking people to leave the
Capitol and Ron DeSantis doesn't have
any opinion on that
look I know by the way I'm pretty sure I
know who that high school student was he
goes to every town hall meeting in New
Hampshire he's been to three of mine and
he asked really tough questions and I
said to him the last time I had a town
hall meeting he was out of mind see if
any of the candidates will answer your
questions directly
um and grade them on it they won't they
won't so listen again we don't have to
now rehabilitate Chris Christie into
some hero
it is a very useful thing to see a
republican drop some truth bombs on
maggots or magedonians or megapotamians
I think that that is a good thing he
Chris Christie was complicit in the
Trump nonsense for years he stood behind
Trump and endorsed him and the entire
thing and for that he deserves our
criticism and now he is the only guy
running in this primary who's willing to
say some of these things and so we can
praise that here's one more one more
clip
um about uh the January 6th stuff if he
asked
and how would you answer it I would say
it was one of the most disgraceful days
in American history
and that the president was principally
responsible for it right one not a
single other Republican is willing to
say that through the conduct and his
words from election night forward
inciting people and insisting that the
election was stolen when it wasn't
through his speech that day when he
attacked directly his own vice president
and incited those people to be angry at
Mike Pence who was just performing his
constitutional Duty and he had no choice
in every lawyer good lawyer had told
people that that he couldn't do anything
different than that and then while the
event was going on while the riot was
going on on Capitol Hill we know that
Donald Trump was watching it and was
being urged by even members of his own
family to get out there and say
something and he refused
because he was enjoying watching people
yell scream and Destroy things in his
name this is all undeniably true and
Trump will never admit it and insists
that it's fake news Chris Christie
holding steady at 2.5 percent in the
Republican primary the only guy willing
to tell these what should be
uncontroversial truths and uh if I had
to choose from the current Republican
slate who is the next president without
a doubt it would be Chris Christie
one of our sponsors today is replace
your mortgage mortgages are a really
interesting thing in the United States
the poor often can't afford them and the
rich often don't use them instead the
wealthy use special Financial tools to
pay off their debts often in a fraction
of the time that it takes for a
middle-class American to realize that
same payoff replace your mortgage
teaches you how you can pay off your
home in five to seven years without
needing to make more money than you're
currently making right now and in
addition they can teach you how to
better utilize your existing assets and
Equity to beginner continue growing
wealth and passive income through
additional strategies and they actually
have an upcoming Workshop that will show
you how you can take advantage of these
strategies how it all works create your
own economy in a sense you can go to
replace your universe city.com slash
Pacman to watch the interview I did with
their founder Michael Lush to learn how
you can get exclusive access to what can
be a life-changing virtual event the
link is in the description